el día en que el juicio contra derecho o
bien entró en su segunda semana el
jurado escuchó el testimonio del médico
de emergencias que confirmó la muerte de
georg floyd y del jefe de la policía de
mineápolis me daria ra dando el doctor
bradford langenfeld afirmó que la falta
de oxígeno fue la causa más probable del
paro cardíaco de georg floyd
en aquel momento basándome en la
información que poseía sentí que ésta
era la opción más probable de todas
la defensa argumentó que las drogas
podían haber causado también la
insuficiencia en el flujo de oxígeno
floyd fue inmovilizado en el suelo por
echó bing que presionó su cuello con la
rodilla durante alrededor de nueve
minutos y medio pesa que floyd le
gritaba que no podía respirar la defensa
ha argumentado que el uso de la fuerza
fue consistente justificada por el
entrenamiento policial pero al subir a
la tribuna arredondo afirmó que la
presión de chavín sobre el cuello de
floyd violó las normas policiales
si esta política menciona que una
presión consciente sobre el cuello debe
ser ligera
cuando miro la expresión facial del
señor floyd de ningún modo parece que se
esté ejerciendo una presión moderada
arredondo expulsó a chopin ya los otros
tres agentes involucrados en la muerte
de floyd un día después del trágico
suceso la ciudad de mineápolis ya llegó
a un acuerdo con la familia de freud por
27 millones de dólares el juicio que se
puede ver en directo por televisión está
siendo seguido de cerca por muchas
personas que ven este momento como un
ajuste de cuentas para la justicia
racial y la reforma policial en eeuu